here are the questions Ralph read how
important is the evangelical vote in the
Republican primaries well in Iowa it's
everything it's 56 to 60 percent of the
vote in Iowa right now if you look at
the Des Moines Register Bloomberg
politics poll that came out I guess a
couple of days ago it has Cruz getting
37% of that vote in a 11 person field so
the Trump is where Trump is probably low
20s so if that stays where it is he'll
win the Iowa caucuses growth based on
the strength of his over performance
among that vote there is still but isn't
that always doctor been really the most
jesusí of all of them is Jesus see a
technical term there a garson's voters
know technology in your area
we're dealing strictly with the ether
here
I don't know when when he when he when
he divided the fish in the bread I think
that people ate yeah people well of
course that's a story written down in a
book 2,000 years old and even the people
who wrote it were not contemporaries of
Jesus there there are as many can
remember Irenaeus accounts of his
ministry there are there are a Saddles
life there are none gossip excuse me
Ralph excuse me
the Gospels were written from 70 to 110
AD he died in 33 st. Paul lived in the
50s not the 1930 there are no
contemporary accounts of Jesus you must
know that there you know as I said there
are contemporary I would like hell there
I don't know whether or not they were
written later or not doesn't vitiated
the fact doc would you please referee
this there are no Kundera there are
perennial truths like love thy neighbor
as that not I do unto others as you have
rather do on not the question in terms
of the particular writings of the text
it certainly occurs decades after than
attempt to thank people I the city will
read it's by the it's by the
eyewitnesses who were there no it's not
mark Matthew's Gospel he wrote it in the
year 70 it's 40 years after Jesus was 37
37 okay okay yeah but not a contemporary
so you're saying that if I write if I
write something 37 years from now which
says I'm using just I say contemporaries
because they're nothing what we have a
issue with definition of terms right a
contemporary is someone who lived at the
same time the answer to the original
question is the evangelical vote is
going to be very important
whatever your personal views are Jesus's
followers are still around and they vote
oh I know are the wrong man that was a
nice man his King because we're both
Christian Telepictures wrong about a lot
of things divide your panel what don't
seek to divide your panels ugly I mean I
never understood why black people wanted
to adopt the god of the slave master do
you know that Hebrew Scriptures that
have an oppressed and persecuted people
what God says you are subordinated but I
make a covenant with you all you have to
do is you just Lee love mercy walk
humbly with thy God and you will have a
sense of dignity that allows you to
stand in the face of Pharaoh
there's just something about you that
sparks a sermon and all of it oh that
was a good another good way it's the
best way to spread your [ __ ] what do
you make what do you make of criticism
that Oscar nominees didn't represent a
diverse enough pool of actors oh I think
it's a real shame but I think the
problem to be honest isn't really the
Oscars I don't think they should take
that responsibility I think it's
Hollywood in general who's making the
movies who's being allowed to direct
those movies who's being allowed to be
in those movies okay let's start Jenny
Mac that's right it's always a strange
phenomenon to me that Hollywood the most
liberal place in the world
when 12 years a slave won the Oscar
several Oscar voters admitted we never
saw the movie
we just knew it should be the bright
choice who is that right that's very
liberal yes and they always pick I mean
if you have AIDS or you're a slave you
always going to win the Oscar
don't [ __ ] with me birthday is here to
fail but I mean it's true you know if
you play somebody who is some sort of
affliction you're gonna what you could
all Republican Julianne Moore an Emmy it
was an Emmy but still okay Republicans
they really do a little bit okay but why
if they're so liberal do they have this
prejudice against nominating black
people you think they would bend over
backwards to nominate the black people
could it possibly be I mean who was it
up for Will Smith they wanted a nominee
or other will it maybe a maybe could it
possibly be just that the other five
actually did a better acting job I'm
just asking that's that mean I think I
mean I think I think the Leonardo is
just a jack and you know that about that
but I think this is shot raped by a bear
come on he's got it's like it's like
aids time slaves
is crap
dr. west what is the future of the black
lives matter movement well I hope it's a
strong future though but it's not a
movement yet it's a moment it has
momentum it's not a movement until is
able to sustain itself bring in
significant allies that keep to keep
their eyes on the prize which is freedom
and justice for everybody but it begins
on the chocolate side of town because
often time chocolate brothers and
sisters overlook when you talk about
abstract Universal category right matter
connecting and then bringing us all in
did you see this do you think about this
87 years ago today Martin Luther King
jr. was born my precious Alberta his
mother I was at this january 15 1929 his
spirit can still be operating Breanna
asks I'm guessing not the same although
she is a fan I know that I introduced
her at the American Music Awards is Bill
Clinton a liability or an asset on the
campaign trail for Hillary oh that's an
interesting question the answer is the
answer is both both yeah he's a bit he's
a major asset and he's also a liability
and he's a liability not only because of
Trump the LEAs issue or it these issues
related to his past
you know mistreatment of women but also
he's the natural also the fact that
knows where the jugular is in everybody
right Bill Clinton is such a gifted
politician that Hillary actually looks
worse than I normally would or contrast
that's true that's so true thing about
him is he allowed Trump to raise not his
conduct know everybody knows what he did
and nobody held it against him even at
the time he had a 67 percent approval
rating the week he was impeached well
some people hold it against less a few
yeah yes but people in your party I'm
talking about the voters the public he
was probably right in there more than
60% of the country is well
they're gonna shoot anybody here unless
they miss you're fine I don't know about
red okay I get the competition is the
issue of her conduct during those years
and you know I would have thought a lot
of people thought she was the victim
that her husband cheated but that is not
the case there was a pretty robust
debate about her conduct or treatment of
Lewinsky I'm on that okay I'm gonna go
eat my cake thank you very much
everybody